morning everybody seven o'clock i'm back
the oscars also are back not with a bang
but a slap will smith won the best actor
award for his portrayal of richard
williams the father of the tennis stars
of venus and serena the ceremony will be
remembered for what happened a few
moments earlier when smith walked onto
the stage and smacked the comedian chris
rock in the mouth for making a joke
about his wife art imitates life i look
at the crazy father who said afterwards
we're live in la fuji it's monday the
28th of march
oh
richard
[Laughter]
oh wow
wow
just a few minutes after this happened
will smith won best actor for his
performance in king richard
with tears rolling down his face will
smith was forced to use his acceptance
speech to apologize to the academy for
slapping chris rock
rowing back president biden insists he
wasn't calling for regime change in
russia when he said putin cannot remain
in
for regime power
no
more talks taking place this morning
with president zielinski suggesting
ukraine could adopt a neutral status as
part of a deal with russia
the government pledges to drive up
standards for maths and english in
school speaking to the education
secretary in just a few moments
plus one city two lock downs shanghai to
shut down one half at a time in a bid to
halt rising covet cases
also on the programme for you this
morning wherever you're watching us
around the world we'll speak to one of a
group of vets who've come together to
help people and animals alike in ukraine
and william and kate's caribbean tour
we'll talk about how some things
appeared to go so badly wrong with the
royal biographer angela levin
[Music]
morning everybody it was an
extraordinary night at the oscars in the
space of a few moments will smith came
on stage and appeared to smack the host
chris rock in the mouth for making a
joke about his wife and then he won the
award for best actor
oh richard
oh wow
wow
smith won best actor for his portrayal
of richard williams the driven father
who raised tennis stars venus and serena
accepting the award he offered a tearful
apology to the academy
i know
to do what we do
you got to be able to take
abuse you got to be able to have people
talk crazy about you
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you i want to
apologize to the academy i want to
apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
more on the oscars later in the program
first the education secretary nadim
zahawi is with us good morning minister
thank you so much for joining us on the
programme this morning um we're going to
hear more about the education white
paper you're very keen to highlight the
increase or likely increase in funding
uh returning to 2010 levels by 2024-25
why do you think that's a success
well we had to come through uh the
financial crisis uh and of course
then the pandemic where we've
put 400 billion to work to support jobs
and the economy
to be able then in the spending review
to um
have seven billion being invested in uh
schools in education taking the total
budget for schools alone to 56 over 56
billion
um so my total budget in the education
department is 86 billion by 24.25
um i think that's important uh which is
why and by the way that seven billion is
front loaded so
four billion of it is uh coming early to
make sure that we have the investment in
our schools uh teachers have done an
excellent job to make sure that 99.9 of
schools
um uh opened and remained open through
omicron so that investment is really
important
it means i hope
we can
complete the journey which is what my
paper does
of
a family of schools which is all the
evidence suggests that schools that work
together in a family of schools that's
tightly uh managed really well supported
by a strong and i underlined strong
high-performing multi-academy trust
deliver better outcomes for the children
i'm very fond of talking about my
background of being the 11 year old who
couldn't speak a word of english but
with parents i had the wherewithal to
push me in and look where i am today i
want the system to work for every child
wherever they are at the right place at
the right time even with those whose
parents don't have the wherewithal or
have no parents that's what the white
paper will do it's a real um
ambitious target to make sure every
school in our country is high performing
in that family of uh schools working
together so let's go back to why you say
that um there have been challenges on
the budget of course it's affected every
department but the health budget has
increased by 42.4 percent by 2025 since
2010 the department of education only
2.8
so there is the money there
so what the chancellor's done if you
look actually across government and
health has had a a big uplift because of
the pandemic clearly we had to deal i
was the the vaccine deployment minister
in health at the time um
but education has also now
caught up in in the sense that we've got
seven billion going into schools uh
we've got 3.8 billion going into skills
you see on my lapel that tl t levels
tori leader as we always say well it's
it's actually a fusion between an a
level and a uh
a an apprenticeship uh that is what a t
level and we will make them as famous as
a levels um over 80 um universities now
except t levels or you can go straight
into work as well um so look the
investment is there uh the white paper
outlines how we're gonna get there uh
the first thing you've got to do by the
way the most important thing and the
greatest predictor of outcomes is a
great teacher in the classroom we're
investing a quarter of a billion in half
a million teacher training opportunities
so from the early careers framework to
the initial teacher training to the
later on in life sort of professional
development big investment in teaching a
big
target to take at the moment only
two-thirds of children complete primary
school
um with the ability to read write and do
maths to an acceptable level two-thirds
that's not good enough i want to get
that only spend five grand of people on
well i want to get that to
percent we don't 90
enough money
so the oecd i had andrea schleicher from
the oecd in my office um a couple of
weeks ago he said on schools you're
right up uh in terms of
investment in education um
compared to other oecd countries um
that's a good thing um now
how that money spent sometimes because
the netherlands consistently places
higher than the uk in world education
rankings they've pledged over six times
the amount of catch-up funding per pupil
in the uk so i've got five billion as
well as seven billion i've got five
billion in catch-up money you remember
when i was doing the vaccines yeah right
i wasn't interested in how many vaccines
we had in the warehouse i want to know
how many we get them people's arms i've
got five billion to spend on the
national tutoring program as part of
that getting those
children with the least time left in
education to 16 19 year olds uh 800
million of that money and of course
focusing on disadvantaged children in
primary and secondary let me get that
money into the system make sure that
those
students are getting that additional
help which they are we've got a million
blocks of uh tutoring that have already
been delivered we're gonna deliver
another million by the end of this
school year six million in total by the
end of this parliament
and i i'm will always be
data driven evidence-driven i will
evaluate and i'll look how far we've got
we're doing well on primary school
reading and maths catch up we need to do
better at secondary and i'll always go
back for more but let me actually get
this right there's no point having a
sort of arms race how much can i
announce i'm spending
i've got to make sure it's actually
working in the system scale is hard in
anything you do but having 10 000
academies already is great i've got 22
000 schools in england i want to
complete that journey but complete it
with quality and i'm just need the money
to do that the catch-ups are so kevin
collins
he resigned didn't he um he said
the proposal that he presented the
government was for 15 billion pounds
worth of funding why do you think he
resigned
well there was clearly a um a
disagreement as to
the
people on you ask him to to be an expert
and then he presents this report and you
ignore him no no this is i have a lot of
time for kevin collins i worked with him
in fact when i was children and families
minister in the department four years
ago why do you think he resigned there
was a disagreement over the the quantum
of investment what i'm saying to you is
i've got seven billion uh going into
investment in schools i've got five
billion on recovery um let me do this
well and i can demonstrate to kevin
collins and the rest of the country how
well we've done on catch-up
tutoring used to be the privilege of
fortunate parents wealthier parents it's
now available to every parent i want
parents watching this program this
morning to ask their schools are they
participating in the national tutoring
program because we want to make sure
that we deliver six million blocks of 15
hours of tutoring for children for
recovery down to the money minister we
have five billion and i'm i'm going to
say 16 billion is what the
catch-ups are says with respect to uh
kevin i don't i'm not interested in sort
of announcing big numbers i'm just
saying how we're going to spend it to
deliver but i think we're interested in
actually big numbers but we have the big
numbers from the chancellor's saying
that you know the big cheers in the
house of commons we're going to take you
back up to 2010 levels um 14 years after
we took power
so look the the
how is that successful well i tell you
why because
we've had to come through a financial
crisis um
if we hadn't taken the tough decisions
then we wouldn't be able to spend the
400 billion 400 billion that the chances
spent
protecting jobs protecting businesses
small businesses
making sure that 14 million people
had that net of protection through the
furlough scheme and then we were hit by
a global pandemic you know but other
departments have that problem as well
and as i said it's chump change what you
get or you're getting compared to the
national health service i hear what you
say about them and needing the money for
the pandemic
let's talk about kids in schools though
when it comes to food you know a lot of
them need to have
a hot meal at school because that's the
only time they get it half a million
children are in absolute poverty
so i saw the resolution foundation
works i think what you're referring to
um what the chance has done um is
earmarked 22 billion for this one year
coming because of the we're in a global
battle okay against inflation what does
that mean it means that your weekly shop
is increasing your utility bills are
increasing 22 billion for one year of
help nine billion of it is going into
helping people with energy costs he's
already announced that in february we'll
always review that we'll look what what
more we can do but part of that this
friday
the um national living wage will
increase which means people get a
thousand pounds in schools i mean i'm
sure that you'll be as appalled as i was
to hear about a 14 year old boy in
wandsworth who was in the queue at a
food bank collapsed through hunger and
had to be taken to hospital that that's
21st century britain come on well that's
i agree that's heartbreaking which is
why i'm saying to you that the money the
22 billion i'm just trying to describe
to you where it's going yeah right nine
billion going towards energy one billion
so the chancellor in the um spring
statement double the amount going to
local government your question about
onesworth onesworth will know where
those families are that need the most
help the ones that you just described to
me at the food bank or the ones who are
really struggling with their utility
bills but you acknowledge that you
should not happen which is why
which is why he doubled the amount going
to local government so they can help
those people directly uniquely to be
able to go to those households and say
look there is help available for you 22
billion
in one year
is a you know a big number but we're not
resting on our laurels we're not saying
job done we're saying we'll keep an eye
on this because
energy prices are volatile at the moment
um there is a global battle against
inflation
in america in europe everywhere but no
school child should go hungry in 20 i
don't disagree with i was the the
minister when i was children who
introduced the holiday activities and
food program with frank field we started
with 10 million pounds
labor absolutely right um it's now
running at 220 million a year and we've
got the funding for the next three years
to continue to deliver holiday
activities and food program we're coming
into a holiday
period now i'm very proud of the work
we've done
on that we continue to support we've
just announced free school meals for uh
children of parents with no recourse to
public funds um which is important to
make sure that
that child doesn't go hungry either so
we're doing a lot of work in this area
in the department the important thing is
education
actually unlocks opportunity you know
it's only when i began to think in the
language you know i remember remember
having to learn and then read and try
and speak as well as i can when i
started to think in the language and the
best thing i can do for children is make
sure there's a great teacher uh with a
school that's strong and well supported
in a family of schools everywhere from
noseley to kensington i don't believe
that a child in noseley is less talented
than a child in kensington right they
just don't have the opportunity and i'm
going to deliver that forward okay but
your former vaccines minister why do you
think it's appropriate
uh to stop you
having free lateral flow tests
so for nhs stuff particularly so
the secretary of state for health will
say a bit more on this on the first uh
of april uh on what we're doing on
testing um
the important thing to remember is is we
have to live with
the virus our first line of defense is
vaccine he's already announced a
further fourth jab for the most
vulnerable uh in society but i'm sure
about lateral closure i i hear the
second line of defense is the
therapeutics and the antivirals which
he's had the foresight started java to
buy those as well um now in some uh
parts of the economy where uh we need to
to have further
work in terms of testing he will say
more on that
but actually
between vaccine and our radar system the
ability to genome sequence i think we're
in a strong place to now continue to
live with the virus we're gonna have to
live with it i don't know for how long
maybe five six seven ten years but if
people are going to um um elderly care
homes or whatever they need to have a
test in order to go into that that's
twelve hundred and sixty pounds a year
something like that is is the average
calculation that's a tax on caring well
he'll say more about
what
will happen on
lateral flow devices on the first of
april but
ultimately we're going to have to live
with this virus it is through the
vaccination program that you're going to
protect populations it's great that you
know the uk population now has very high
levels of antibodies because of the
vaccination program not just the the one
i was responsible for but then the
booster campaign where he delivered so
brilliantly javid and of course now the
fourth jab and the antivirals and
therapeutics we have to get to a place i
think where we transition this virus
from pandemic to endemic we're well on
our way we're probably the first major
economy i mean just watching what's
happening in china you know this idea
where people had a sort of zero covert
strategy is clearly not working it's a
this is a virus that is aerosol
transmitted it is a respiratory virus
it's never going to work the best thing
you can do is protect the population
through vaccination and then continue to
make sure that the protection is there
for the most vulnerable all the time
and we're almost out of time but i just
wanted to know what you thought about
what president biden said did he
misspeak
on at the weekend when he was talking
about regime change in russia well both
the white house and uh the president
have been clear on this we are in
lockstep with them that is up to the
russian people to decide who governs
them and the uh future but they could
remain in power well
i hate but um do you back those words
well no i what i would say is up to the
russian people i think russian peoples
are pretty fed up uh not only because
they're they're watching their you know
their friends and some of them have
family um uh in ukraine who've been
attacked um by the putin regime you know
clearly war crimes have been committed
because they're targeting
innocent
uh civilians in civilian areas the
deputy prime minister is working with
the international criminal court to make
sure that that evidence is in place but
i think president biden is right to say
that putin has no place in the ukraine
uh they have to make sure that they
withdraw from ukraine because it's an
illegal invasion of the ukraine i think
he's absolutely right in that
ultimately it's the russian people who
decide who governs them do you agree
that is a butcher
well i think there are war crimes have
been committed in the ukraine no doubt
in my mind the evidence is clear on that
it's right to collect that evidence
because it's also important you know my
family had experience with saddam
hussein um it's important that despots
and dictators
understand that there will be a
reckoning
and that reckoning will come through
the international criminal court in the
hague as we've seen in bosnia and of
course in other parts of the world it's
really important
this is not something that um should be
taken lightly that someone can
go into a a a country illegally uh and
start bombing civilians um and and feel
that uh there there is no um
there there is no response from the
global community and i think uh in many
ways the coming together of the world in
this way has sent a very clear message
to any dictator that they're not going
to be able to get away with in 2022 yeah
absolutely right um it's great to see
you as always thank you very much indeed
for joining us thank you very much
minister thank you quick look at what's
happening as far as the papers are
concerned this morning the front pages
the telegraph leads with the forelight
from joe biden's comments about a regime
change in russia they say president
macron france has also been trying to
mitigate the political
damage the eye leads on claims from
ukrainian military intelligence that
russia is planning to split the country
into two along the lines of north and
south korea
the express reports that the chancellor
is planning to cut council tax for
millions of people to help with the cost
of living crisis and finally the staff
focuses on the way piano ferries is
being run after those mass sackings
earlier this month with the headline all
at sea
let's return to l.a should we and the
oscars accepting his award for best
actor will smith said i want to
apologize to the academy i want to
apologize to all my fellow nominees just
a few minutes earlier he'd walked onto
the stage and slapped the comedian chris
rock for making a joke about his wife
here's katie spencer
oh wow
it wasn't supposed to be like this will
smith going off script losing his temper
at chris rock keep my wife's name out
i'm going to okay
apparently having enough of jokes at his
wife jada's expense
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television
i know
to do what we do
you got to be able to take
abuse you got to be able to have people
talk crazy about you
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you
and you got to smile and you got to
pretend like that's okay that at your
highest moment be careful that's when
the devil comes for you
his speech becoming a disturbing
demonstration of the pressures of fame
and the intensity of hollywood
okay coda
but will smith's trauma aside a landmark
moment for representation as a little
indie film called coda won best picture
[Applause]
and for an event famed for
self-indulgence there's a lot of
compassion for others in the speeches
this is dedicated to the deaf community
sir kenneth branagh also dedicating his
first ever oscar to others we will never
forget
all of those lost in the heartbreaking
heartwarming
human story of that amazing city of
belfast
and jessica chastain echoing that theme
suicide is a leading cause of death in
the united states it's touched many
families it's touched mine
and especially members of the lgbtq
community
the war would inevitably feature
appropriately from ukrainian-born mila
kunis
recent global events have left many of
us feeling gutted
yet when you witness the strength and
dignity of those facing such devastation
it's impossible to not be moved by their
resilience
but it will no doubt be remembered as
the one where will smith slapped chris
rock rather than celebratory thanks a
winner forced to say sorry i want to
apologize to the academy i want to
apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
hoping academy invites me back thank you
katie's with us now in la hi katie um
looks like you're having a ball there
love the dress love it um what on earth
was all that about
look what a strange night kay nobody saw
that coming i have to say look vanity
fair is the party where they all come to
hang out with people that are turning up
with their gold statuettes we've been
trying to try and stop people to try and
get their reactions and find out what
they they thought of what happened
tonight will smith of course a hugely
popular man in this town
nobody is willing to say anything so far
nobody has wanted to comment a lot of
people that were at the oscars that
we've spoken to kevin costner we just
got a moment ago said he was backstage
at the time we're getting that a lot a
lot of people were backstage didn't see
it don't want to comment on it so
it's one of those things it was just a
strange strange moment when we watched
it we at first
were thinking is this some sort of stage
choreographed moment it just didn't seem
like something will smith hollywood nice
man would would end up doing
in his defense should we be taking into
account the fact that he has been under
a terrific amount of pressure this award
season the focus has been entirely on
him throughout this but i mean this was
his moment 30 years within the industry
he's pretty much ruined his night it's
all with anyone is going to be talking
about now the speech that he gave he was
in tears he was talking about protecting
his family it ended up having to be an
apology to the academy it certainly did
not go to plan
very unlikely he's going to turn up here
i have to say kay we will be trying
tonight to try and get some reaction for
people but certainly i think everyone's
just really a bit stunned that this
actually did happen
isn't it that i mean it's what a couple
of years now since people have been able
to get together am i right in saying for
uh the oscars so there's a freestyle of
excitement getting to the vanity fair
party etc etc
yeah absolutely it always is quite fun
especially when people do come through
with their statuettes it has been a
great night for british winners as well
i mean we had um riz ahmed winning his
uh first actor along with daniel cassia
for live action short who actually had
on sunrise just a few months ago talking
about that short and also had sir
kenneth branagh winning it was touch and
go whether or not he was going to make
it to the ceremony because he caught
covered after the baftas thankfully he
was managed to make it to the ceremonies
pick up his first ever oscar so
hopefully we are hoping they will come
our way tonight i actually can see out
the corner of my eye not necessarily a
recognizable name but um the visual
effects people from june june came
across with the most uh awards tonight
picking up six uh so it's been a really
good night but yeah just completely sort
of overshadowed by this very strange
moment with will smith i would imagine
he's going home to bed not really sort
of feeling like feeling like he's done a
very good job of
performing tonight okay katie for now
thanks very much thank you
still to come on the programme for you
this morning at 7 30 joined by an
adviser to the ukrainian president
vladimir zelinski to get his view on the
latest round of peace talks
2028 will get reaction to what we've
just heard from nadim zahawi with the
general secretary of the national
education union
on just after eight we'll speak to
labour's alison mcgovern about the cost
of living crisis
[Music]
before that though the chinese city of
shanghai is to be divided in half for a
two-part lockdown which will see
authorities roll out an experimental
kovi testing regime tom has more for us
in beijing hi tom uh just when we
thought that it was safe to and not have
the lateral flows anymore this is
happening
morning k yeah i mean it might seem
extraordinary two years into the
pandemic in shanghai 26 million people
are going to be locked down but this is
china's zero covered strategy as it
calls it and it has worked really well
so far they've only registered around 4
600 official deaths but omicron has
arrived here we've seen waves outbreaks
all across the country now some cities
have locked down entirely some provinces
have locked down entirely sealed
themselves from china shanghai has been
trying to do something different it's
tried targeted lockdowns telling
individuals to stay at home and what
it's trying to do now is not have a
full-on lockdown to restrict the spread
just to lock down so that they can get
26 million people tested um over the
course of eight days they've said that
lockdown will come to an end there uh so
this is sort of precision testing but at
mass scale if you will but the question
is becoming can china keep the zero
covered up uh if they find lots of cases
in shanghai will they have to lock down
it's the only tool they have left and
will china ever learn to live with kobe
there's no indication from the
authorities yet they're willing to
change their approach especially with
their elderly population relatively
unvaccinated this is about buying time
beating off uh this wave to build those
defenses so that china finally can
perhaps someday down the line learn to
live with kovid okay fenay thanks very
much tom thanks for explaining that to
us um it's been lovely hasn't it uh the
last few days stand by
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
cooler and more unsettled this week
sadly wintry showers for some it was
nippy this morning some people might
even see
a bit of snow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
check out these pictures that we found
for you in the papers this morning katie
in charge of pictures in the papers but
first have a look at this thousands of
people have fled their homes as a
philippine volcano continues to erupt
um looking at this image in the
telegraph
and this is an elderly lady as you can
see who has uh succumbed to events in
ukraine
and the eye they have this picture of
some artwork at sotheby's which just
happens to be a massive
32 feet long the piece depicts the
battle of polio in india which took
place between british east india company
troops and the forces of the tipu sultan
back in 1780 the clash was described as
the severest blow that the british ever
sustained in india that's pretty
comprehensive for you
set to go to auction on wednesday
expect it to fetch between five and
eight hundred thousand pounds
which is nice and the times lady in red
this is kirsty macleod who's from near
glastonbury she spent wait for it 13
years working with 343 artisans from 46
different countries embroidering this
dress to tell women's stories and uh
there you go how stunning is that
glorious
hello again everybody monday morning
breakfast show here on sky news um hope
you're ready for the week ahead the
weather it's going to get colder we'll
tell you more about that to come but
first our top stories for you this
morning oh
richard
oh wow
wow
will smith has apologized after
appearing to slap chris rock shortly
before winning the oscar for best actor
at the ceremony in los angeles
president biden has said he wasn't
calling for regime change in russia when
he said that vladimir putin cannot
remain in power
and the education secretary has told
this program reports of children
collapsing at food banks are
heartbreaking as the government prepares
to set out its new school's white paper
[Music]
in the last half an hour the education
secretary has told this program that no
children should go hungry in 21st
century britain
i'm sure that you'll be as appalled as i
was to hear about a 14 year old boy in
wandsworth who was in the queue at a
food bank collapsed through hunger and
had to be taken to hospital
that's 21st century britain come on well
that's i agree that's heartbreaking
which is why i'm saying to you that the
money the 22 billion i'm just trying to
describe to you where it's going yeah
right nine billion going towards energy
one billion so the chancellor in the um
spring statement double the amount going
to local government your question about
wandsworth onesworth will know where
those families are that need the most
help i also spoke to the education
secretary about unfolding events in
ukraine he told me that he thinks war
crimes have been committed in the
country and said there would be a
reckoning for dictators
i think their war crimes have been
committed in the ukraine no doubt in my
mind the evidence is clear on that it's
right to collect that evidence because
it's also important you know my family
had experience with saddam hussein
it's important that despots and
dictators
understand
that there will be a reckoning
and mara is here with us now for her
take on what's going on tomorrow's
second nine o'clock of course but a
quick thought on what we heard so the
education secretary says that you know
he's appalled by the idea that children
are going hungry uh in 2022. he's
announcing a whole load of new targets
today for schools including that
children leaving primary school should
be meeting acceptable standards in
reading writing and maths he says only
65 percent of them do at the moment he
wants it to be 90
in 2030 still some way off now labor and
some of the unions are saying does this
whole plan lack a bit of ambition isn't
this what parents should expect already
and some in the education world saying
that this cannot be divorced from the
cost of living crisis because if
children haven't got enough food haven't
got enough heating aren't in the right
housing then it's very difficult for
them to meet these targets at school the
education secretary says that although
there's no new money being announced
today that all the money the five
billion pounds announced for catch-up
after covid would feed into this but
still there's been a lot of criticism
that even the schemes the government has
already announced like tutoring to help
those who are falling behind have not
been as well targeted as they could be
so he'll be judged on whether these
targets
are advanced towards but of course these
targets are still years away from being
realized okay tomorrow's take nine
o'clock as i said looking forward to it
thanks very much indeed he also talked
actually about uh ukraine um let's talk
about it in more detail should we
president zielenski has suggested that
the country could adopt neutrality as
part of a peace agreement with russia
more peace talks will take place today
in turkey let's speak to oleg ustenko
economic adviser to the ukrainian
president hello to sir thank you so much
for taking the time to join us on the
programme uh let's just start with the
situation update should be what's it
like in kiev today
so look uh the whole night in here we
heard sirens all the time people were
hidden in the bomb shelters almost the
whole time only you know a couple of
hours uh very close already this time
people were able uh to get out from the
bomb shelters
uh russians continued to bomb
the whole country um you know that
already some cities are completely
destroyed for example the city of
which we all knew before
completely destroyed not like 95 percent
as we claimed before completely
destroyed you will not be able to find
any
place in the city which is not destroyed
60 70 percent of the city of syria is
almost destroyed uh russian soldiers are
bombing and sending the missiles to
social infrastructure again more than a
hundred hospitals were destroyed and the
city of parkev is almost uh is 70
destroyed so every everything they
continue they continue to send their
missiles and what really you know
um troubled me is that uh best is still
sending bloody money to vladimir putin
buying gas from russia buying oil from
russia is is
he is translated to making the crime
look when we are talking about
sending money uh sending money to regime
of vladimir putin
uh in terms of buying the oil and not
putting an embargo an oil embargo
it means that we are sending global we
are sending 1 billion u.s dollars daily
daily uh to finance russian russian
military machine it's completely
unacceptable
after after united states already
introduced embargo on russian oil europe
is still not doing the same we see the
we see
discussions we see
[Music]
plans we see politicians who are making
different statements but in our view
it's completely
unacceptable for us here in here for our
people who are needed to be hidden in
shelters
kids who are killed 150 people if 150
children were already killed in ukraine
more than a thousand women were already
raped by russian soldiers we fix
everything and our general prosecutor
office is also fixing another
information information related to
finance and war crime because everybody
who is sending the money to finance
military machine of russia for us is
also a financing a war crime we are
keeping all this information we are
keeping information in terms of
delivering of russian
oil from all russian ports all over the
world we established a special group
which is 24 hours seven days a week
tracking the movements of all russian
ships for russian imports and what is
really terrible that some of these ships
are still going to europe so the
question which i am rising is how it
could be
the whole civilized world is trying to
stop this war
together with ukrainians
but at the same time sending money to
finance this war is completely is
completely unacceptable so we are going
to be in this war and we are going to
sue everybody everybody who was
financing the killing of our people when
he was buying or she was buying or the
company was buying the oil from russia i
wonder if i could ask you this um i'm
just uh reading that the ukrainian
president um your boss has said that
boris johnson our prime minister is
helping more than other leaders in the
resistance against russia thanks to the
pressure direct pressure from the
british people
whereas uh it goes on to say in the
interview
that the french president is afraid of
russia
do you echo those sentiments by the
president
oh yes absolutely
and i mean already since uh the
beginning of invasion and even before
that time i understand that uh
boris johnson and uh
they were always in touch on the on
different methods but including matters
related to our security
it's definitely not my topic
but yes
this is absolutely right i know that
they are in constant dutch i know that
they have always
taken the positions to see each other i
know that the great supporter of ukraine
is
the united kingdom and we are very
grateful and we appreciate all the
support we are having from this great
country from the from you from your
great country and we know that uh it's
it's it's not it's it's not the question
of even
uh
economic health or financial support
it's not about humanitarian support
which we are also uh receiving from the
uk and it's not about our refugees who
are currently also he within the uk but
it's also about the attitude of people
of
the united kingdom which we feel here in
uh you know in our uh bomb shelters
all over
ukraine so really we are extremely
grateful for that but we need to do more
we need to
to stop putting and for me to stop
putting it's not only you know our brave
our brave soldiers who are fighting
against this army it's not our people
who are
fighting against the russian army um
but it's also
it's also an economic steps which we
have to make and this economic step for
me which is an immediate step
this week this week we have to cut off
uh his machine out of this bloody money
he is receiving for his oil and also
look remember that 40 percent of the
russian
budget revenue is coming from oil 40
so can you imagine if we are cutting
this if we are cutting off his regime
out of this money it means that they
will not be able to buy missiles to buy
other weapons
bombs uh to kill our people in ukraine
so i i think that we need to do that and
we need to put
pressure for those who still
are trying to make uh their minds and i
am talking here about germans it's like
it's completely unacceptable you know
it's it's not the time uh when german
can continue
uh to discuss the issue the issue is
very clear either you are on our side or
you are trying to play the games and you
are
financing this military machine against
us this is unacceptable yeah and and
it's not because of uh you know even
economic issues it's because of morality
and i do not accept and in key we do not
accept any thoughts like uh it's going
to be negative economic consequences yes
they are going to be but they are going
to be in a very short run yes in a very
short process one final question before
i let you go i know that um time is
pressing and we really appreciate you
taking the time to join us this morning
how do you think the peace talks will go
there's another round of talks in turkey
isn't the later
yes
our group is already
today
they are starting today
we have a lot of hopes for these talks
uh
i think that this is
you
i i could not comment more on this issue
okay
um please keep safe um we do appreciate
you taking the time to join us be safe
in the knowledge i don't know if you saw
the demonstration
in one of our squares in central london
trafalgar square at the weekend tens and
tens of thousands of brits and tourists
as well who are all carrying your flags
and uh standing united with the people
of ukraine um please be aware that there
is support for you here in the united
kingdom thank you absolutely i
appreciate that very much and thank you
for uh that you are standing this thank
you very much appreciate appreciate very
much what might be happening on behalf
of my president
thank you very much for joining us thank
you
brave men one and all aren't they and
women
let's get more now on the government's
forthcoming schools white paper and
plans for schools to offer a 32 and a
half hour school week by 2023 joined now
by the general secretary of the national
education union that's kevin courtney hi
kevin thanks for joining us on the
program this morning i'm sure you heard
the education secretary speaking on this
program just a few moments ago what did
you make of what he had to say
well i didn't actually hear because i
was uh the sun wasn't coming through but
i've been talking with civil servants uh
before today about what the white paper
says and i've seen some of the things
that he's been saying and i have to say
this is the first school's white paper
for six years
and i'm afraid it's a damp square but it
doesn't address the things that we have
learned coming through the pandemic it
doesn't deal with this significant issue
of child poverty it doesn't deal with
school funding it doesn't deal with the
profound problem of teacher recruitment
and retention instead nadine sahabi is
setting targets he's setting targets for
children but not putting extra funding
in
or extra support for schools he's
setting targets on this school day
length actually the vast majority of
schools already hit that target and in
this in the few that don't quite often
they've compressed their lunch hour for
a good reason they're a rural school and
they've got difficulties with school
transport etc and then finally he set
this target for schools becoming
adjoining multi-academy trusts where
really he has provided no evidence that
that is a good thing in educational
terms and no proposals for a reform of
maths allowing schools to have a vote in
a mat or allowing schools to leave a mat
if it doesn't provide a good service to
them so a damp script of all white paper
i think
okay although the education secretary if
you were here would say in response
because i did press him on that
particular point he says that he's
managing to get more money for the
department than had previously been
thought possible and he's hopeful that
that money will go where it's needed and
targeted most
well the government appointed kevin
collins uh a year ago in the pandemic of
two years ago in the pandemic to give
them advice on what education needed
post-pandemic and he said that schools
needed 15 billion pounds
in order partly to organize
tutoring inside the school not a
privatized system outside and also that
schools could provide would be given
extra resources to provide
things for children outside the school
that needed uh catch-up needed education
recovery none of that money is coming
through nothing like that 15 billion
kevin collins told us that 15 billion
was roughly speaking what the americans
were putting in what the
what the dutch were putting in we're not
getting that from this white paper so
there is some white there was some money
he announced previously and nadim zahari
is telling us that that money is still
available but it's not new money and
it's not the sort of money that you need
to make the changes in children's lives
that we need to make
what about i didn't get a chance because
we were out of time but i didn't uh
what's happening as far as kovid is
concerned i'm reading that as some
schools 20
uh close 200 000 kids they're off with
covid 19. is it something that's in our
rear view mirror or is it still a real
problem in our schools
i mean
it's a real problem in schools and that
is not to say that i mean the
vaccination has been such an enormous
thing and you can see that it can start
it is the way out of this crisis
but in schools right now
ten percent of staff off with covid
something like that that's leading to
enormous stress on those who are left
behind
so if you look on twitter you can find
head teachers saying things like i'm a
head teacher i've been having to teach
classes all week my my staff are off
sick i'm having to prepare their lessons
uh other staff are having to double up
in that sort of way enormously stressful
in schools so we've been saying to
government
that at the very minimum
they should allow schools to still have
access to testing that if you've got
cold symptoms you should be allowed to
test so that you know if it's a cold and
you can you know you've got a bit of a
sniffle you would still go into school
but the distinguish between a bit of a
sniffle that is a cold weight and still
going to school and covid where you
shouldn't go into school because you
will have end up with more staff more
children being off this is a real worry
for
for teachers for support stuff for head
teachers in the run-up to the sats
where it's clear i mean we've got doubts
about the sats every year i have to
state you we don't think they're they're
that they're not a useful measure but
this year they are
there are schools where the euro 6 class
has been entirely disrupted the stress
on the children building up to those so
we need to really address that remove
those sats remove the leak tables
attached to the stats from it for this
year the same thing is happening in
secondary schools there is real pressure
around the exams
we're in favor of the exams going ahead
but the government should be doing more
to help us control the number of covert
cases in schools so there is less
disruption running up to those exams
okay good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time much appreciated
we're turning now to ukraine and the
humanitarian crisis that has become one
of the defining aspects of the war tom
dannet the founder of street child and
val a volunteer for local charity in
ukraine called pumishka joining us uh
now hello to you both um ladies first um
tell me uh about the challenges that
you're facing val
good morning everyone actually ukraine
and ukrainian people ukrainian children
boys and girls we all
feel um you know disruption of our life
of our you know
lifestyles and
you know lots of people
millions of people
more than 10
million of people are
pushed to live to flee their houses and
their places for living and get adopted
to the new conditions of life
uh life in the world times
and
that's about enormous stress that's
about you know basic needs which are not
met
food uh
water this is what we need right now and
the children
families well-being this is what we need
to restore
but it's
it's highly it's not possible while we
live in the constant fear of shelling of
bombing
and
living under conditions of uh you know
being threatened and being
under fear of death and direct threat to
our health and well-being yeah let me
bring in tom as well if i'm a founder of
street child um tom what are you what
are you doing what's your charity doing
to try to help
yeah thanks okay so
street child wherever we work in the
world partners with great local
organizations on the ground so we're
partnering with bosnica um
that laos charity and we're seeking to
meet those precise needs that she
described right today we're launching a
um we're calling a child friendly center
together with bosnica in um
in ukraine it's a center where children
can come
and
and play and
have some normality
as well as accessing some some basic
services so we're there for the the
children of ukraine we can only make a
difference through partner organizations
on the ground and that's what we're
that's what we're trying to do with the
donations that we're receiving from the
british public um and val tell me a
little bit more about the charity i
think pamisha means smile doesn't it
uh thank you for the question actually
in uh
i'm talking on behalf of local
charitable organization which is uh
called
uae it's not formally interpreted for
smile but yeah you're right this is uh
this can be the project like smile in
the english language and this is the
charitable foundation which has the main
office in the parisian city the region
is in the south eastern part of ukraine
now the main part of the region is
already occupied and the policy is
directly affected by the enormous number
of uh internally displaced people being
evacuated to the parisian which is the
main accepting point of those who come
from marijuana which is
obelisk and other occupied uh regions
town settlements in in the parisian
august uh our charitable foundation have
failed offices in the netherlands and we
still have
a child protection specialists social
workers psychologists who continuously
deliver support for for those who are
directly affected okay so i'm just gonna
jump in there if i may because we're
almost out of time less than a minute
left on the program tom what do people
do who are watching at home if they want
to help if you as quickly as you could
please
yeah donate to street child and we will
get money as quick as we can into the
hands of brilliant people like like val
and her colleagues and um that will make
us help a fantastic difference to
children in unimaginable circumstances
okay guys we must leave it there thank
you for explaining what you're doing you
know that the british public have huge
hearts and i'm sure that they will
support you come back and talk to us
very soon and tell us how you're getting
on thank you
thank you